bevor der block hier los geht meine
damen und herren heute ist mein buch
herausgekommen ja dann geht es wieder
ins applaus für dieses buch entweder in
einer buchhandlung bräuchen er kaufen
oder und in der beschreibung ist offen
aber zunehmend jetzt geht endlich der
block los ich finds irgendwie dass wir
bei den kugeln wieder teurer ausgegeben
und herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem neuen blog meine damen und herren
ihr seht schon ich habe hier meine jacke
an da hinten seht ihr schon einen koffer
sieht nun den definitiv nein ich nehme
euch mal wieder ein paar tage mit auf
reisen zwar fahre ich jetzt erstmal
läuft erstmal zu düsseldorf flughafen
freund vom leiter nach oben zu 1live
kronen morgen in hamburg zwei jahren
suchen die zu meiner familie münchen
köln und das alles passiert in diesem
flughafen wie ich weil ich bin schon
viel zu späte gefahrlos
fick dich jung die drei freunde hier
steht im stau schließen angekommen
unserem wunderschönen hotelzimmer
man kommt hier vorne reinmann geht nach
hier und das war es dann auch schon
beziehen uns jetzt auch kurz rum und
danach gehen wir zur 1live krone
vorbei
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren wir sind wieder
zurück im hotel smart nach der 1live
krone auf jeden fall alles klar
er hat nicht locker für die sehr gute
banker als motiv noch war auf jeden fall
echt eine ganz gute veranstaltung
wir lesen jetzt noch ein bisschen was
aus dem neuen testament und dann gehen
wir auch schlafen
für meinen
den vielfach hamburg wird im hotel
angekommen damen und herren unsere
aussicht ja gibt auf jeden fall
schlimmere auf jeden fall hätte ich
[Musik]
wollte gerade deswegen schaut mal
freunde die sterne
findet dort geführt es ist gerade schon
ein neuer tag freunde
wir sind gestern nachmittag abend noch
zu fixieren gefahren also einem freund
im norden bei familie gepennt und das
film
wir machen garten spaziergang hi dad
also folgende situation
wir hatten diese glorreiche idee an
instagram foto zu machen
instagram wie wir im wasser stehen aber
hat man halt beide keinen bock ins
wasser zu gehen und dann kam felix auf
die idee ich auf diesen stein zu gehen
und dann auf diesem stein und das sind
so circa 30 cm tiefe stellt das vor
der ist richtig jetzt könnt ihr was
richtig überzeugt von seiner idee das
kommt immer näher geht auf diesen stein
geht auf diesen stein und sagte ja ich
habe das recht rutschig
[Applaus]
der rechtsaußen lustig dass seine ärzte
meinte gegen erweitert sein ob mir das
mich nicht erkälten darf sprinten jetzt
so im auto
wenigstens sind
felix und ich haben uns jetzt hier
versammelt weil ich schon wieder 450
daraus gesucht wo er meint das geht sie
erkennen und zwar auch wenn er sie
rückwärts abspielen sondern entscheide
ich mich schon mal auf meinem kanal noch
nie gebracht glaube ich mag es war das
kind heißt wenn ich lukas felix wünsche
mir die songs sind ab und wir mit der
daten was es bei lidl sind beschreibt
einbruch nichts wissen
[Musik]
klasse wie baby oder altersklassen hast
du nicht erkannt weil ich führe auf der
neues album was am 16
woraus kommen ich habe nichts
abgesprochen ich war 22 ok entscheidend
weiter ich dachte hatten sie hinter ihm
war das für dich vermisst
es ist schon wieder weg dann später
freunde des grand slam zu hause das fett
gesetzlicher danke den postens jetzt auf
jeden fall ich zähle
[Musik]
wie spät ist es zu früh freunde wir
haben circa 500 schon geplant ist es
jetzt weiß ich es ist noch früh aber wir
sind jetzt brötchen holt und man also
mein leben ist gerade vorbei wie lange
die pralinen denn hier schrieben der
location asbach uralt du bist hässlich
aber dass du dich so krass herzlich
fühlst
buch meine damen und herren letzten 48
stunden vergangen der beste bulle hat
mal wieder die kamera los geholt ich
bisher gesehen habe und ich gerade auf
dem weg zum bahnhof habe ich finde mich
hingebracht erste kammer geflohen ist
ein praktikum macht und ich bin nach
hause zu meiner familie gefahren als ich
auf dem weg nach hause waren mein auto
mir gesagt hey luca vorne rechts ein
reifen verliert luft und dann wird mein
auto einer werkstatt abgegeben und habe
ein leihwagen bekommen jetzt für zwei
tage und hat die kamera in dem auto
vergessen mich wundert dass das ding
jetzt noch funktioniert weil die einfach
im auto lag draußen bei minus drei grad
über 48 stunden aber ja das war auf
jeden fall jetzt der blog also ich
glaube dass es circa der bescheuerte
blog den ich je gemacht habe bis zuletzt
eher leid ist einfach kein roter faden
vorhanden ist keine richtige story
landen normalerweise ist es ja so ich
sage morgens was wir machen dann machen
wir das beispielsweise zu ikea und darum
handelt sich dann der ganze block darauf
ist der titel aufgebaut wegen wortspiel
macht und danach ist der tag hat vorbei
die da jetzt allerdings nur auf 16 tage
und habe jeden tag einfach nur ein ganz
kleines bisschen immer gefilmt mit
großen zeitspanne dazwischen weiter
trotzdem gefallen wenn es getan hat das
gerne mal ein like da und jetzt gehen
wir ist der block vorbei
[Musik]